[Music]
the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now or next
our media group
number one priority is public safety
without public safety we don't have
anything
tonight on politics now running the city
of henderson mayoral candidate michelle
romero tells us her plans for public
safety
and creating a henderson school district
plus
we're seeing a big increase in
visible street homeless helping the
homeless
an advocate here in the valley tells us
the number one thing needed
and the situation in las vegas right now
and big winners nevada's first raffle
for those with the coronavirus vaccine
and how the first big winner plans to
spend her money
[Music]
from 8 news now this is politics now
thank you very much for joining us i'm
john langler the giveaway is
underway this week nevada started its
coronavirus vaccine raffle
5 million dollars in prizes up for grabs
as long as you're inoculated
on thursday nevada held its first vacs
days raffle more than 200 people in the
first round of winners prizes included
fishing licenses fifty thousand dollars
in scholarship money
and two hundred fifty thousand dollars
of cold hard cash
and the night's big winner of that two
hundred fifty thousand dollars that
woman there north las vegas kindergarten
teacher elizabeth alder
we live paycheck to paycheck i do i have
student loans that i have to pay off and
it's going to be nice
to know that i can do that alder says
the first thing she's going to buy
actually is a car for her mother and
father
the raffle is going to go on for eight
weeks the grand prize one million
dollars
you must have received at least one dose
of the vaccine to be entered to win
governor siselek also says fema
responded to his request for help with
vaccinations
and that assistance will be here next
week so
has this worked as an incentive as the
governor would like to get people
vaccinated
well the raffle was announced on june
17th and back then the average number of
daily vaccinations was more than 7 000 a
day statewide
it has actually declined since then to a
little more than five thousand
that was as of thursday now looking
ahead to the upcoming election season
and we focus on henderson
mayor deborah march is going to be term
limited out of office
two city council members are now vying
for a spot and one is michelle romero
she was elected back in 2019 to the
council after serving as a city's
redevelopment manager
i asked her about why she wants to be
mayor
one of your uh stances is trying to
separate henderson with its own school
district i believe
there's been a long-standing effort to
try and separate ccsd
how would you achieve this goal of
getting henderson its own school
district
well i think we're starting to lay the
groundwork now henderson is the only
city
in the valley that has its own community
education advisory board
and through that board we use 30 percent
of our marijuana funds and 18 percent of
our redevelopment funds to directly fund
henderson public schools and so we've
set the groundwork already for
identifying a funding source and for
ensuring that that our our residents
know that education is top priority
the next thing i've asked our staff to
do and that is already underway is to
looking into
whether or not we can form our own
charter school system
so that we get that already in place and
there's an alternative it'll take a
while to to break up the school district
as you just as you just mentioned and so
we've already done that by establishing
a pre-k
program to make pre-k available to all
children in henderson
we have our own it's operating at full
capacity and it's
it's doing wonderfully well so i'd like
to take that to the next level
and open a charter school and have that
same result
as we continue to work on and allowing
municipalities to separate or opt out of
the school district system
when the discussion of the dollar loan
center as it's called now
uh came up and the deci the votes were
taken to eventually green light the
redevelopment of the pavilion
uh you talk about having people allow
them to have their say
those who were involved the rather vocal
opposition to that project
would suggest they didn't have their say
how do you address
their concerns that i acknowledge the
obviously the arena is being built now
but those are lingering concerns that
were brought up pretty significantly at
that time
so when those people came out i actually
went out and met with them in person i
walked the site with them
i listened to all of their concerns and
and the vast majority of the concerns
were
traffic potential traffic implications
the visibility that
the the building might impede their
visibility
open space and the availability to to
interact in the open space
and parking so all of those ideas i
brought back
and those were all incorporated with the
building design so
parking has been addressed there have
been more than a thousand parking spots
added to the site without disrupting any
of the existing parking
the building will sit actually nine feet
lower than the previous building
so that that that is not an issue the
dollar loan center
is one of many developments happening in
henderson there's the area around the
raiders
practice facility there's water street
which obviously as we were talking
before you are heavily involved in
uh there are some major developments on
the horizon how do you hope to or how do
you plan to if you're elected as mayor
continue that growth and and draw
more development into the city henderson
is very fortunate
in that we have people coming to us now
and so we can afford to be very choosy
about who we allow into the city and we
are looking for what's the highest and
best use for the
the limited space that we have available
and we have a very good vetting process
we have an
excellent economic development team a
great redevelopment team
you know everybody from community
development to fire to police are
looking at every project to make sure
that it
crosses all the teas and dots all the
eyes and meets all of the goals that we
have set for the city
to make sure that we're creating jobs
good paying jobs
that have minimal impacts on the
surrounding area what's your number one
priority if you're elected mayor number
one priority is public safety without
public safety we don't have anything
nobody's going to want to live here
nobody's going to want to send their
child to school
or open a business we've got to make
sure that we have public safety officers
in place
at enough levels to keep our city safe
now we have the full interview with
michelle romero on 8newsnow.com we delve
deeper into the issues of public safety
there was a big change at the police
chief position
not that long ago that's an ongoing
issue transparency we
visit the funding for the dollar loan
center and we're going to invite other
candidates onto our program as well
moving forward
now one other henderson council person
is also running for mayor that is dan
stewart
he announced his plans to run back in
april stewart's also a republican
although the position of mayor is
nonpartisan on the ballot
community safety and economic
development his priorities
before serving on the council stewart
had a career in the construction
industry
based on the last campaign finance
reports back in january stewart's raised
more money than romero 118 thousand
dollars last year while
romero has raised seven thousand five
hundred dollars
also in politics there may be a few
shakeups on the republican side of the
legislature
assemblyman andy matthews says he plans
to run for state controller he's in his
first term in the assembly
right now that position is held by
democrat katherine byrne she's in her
first
term she hasn't said if she plans to run
for re-election
several other republican members of the
assembly are eyeing state
senate seats state senator joe hardy for
example of boulder city is being turned
out
so assembly members glenn levitt and
annie black have both said they plan to
run for that seat
levitt said hardy asked him to run for
the position
state senate minority leader james
suttlemyer is also being termed out that
seat's up in minden
assembly members jim wheeler and robin
titus both plan to run for that position
and on top of that republican
assemblyman tom roberts is also leaving
his position
he plans to run for sheriff here in
clark county
agriculture secretary tom vilsack
visited southern nevada this week
he was here promoting the american
rescue plans food security program
over at henderson's mcdonnell elementary
school
one in four students in clark county are
food insecure
vilsack is pushing to make the one year
long food program
permanent it is an issue of food
security
it is also an issue of nutrition and
what we saw today here
at mcdonald's school is a commitment to
both
making sure that youngsters are fed even
during a pandemic
millions of meals but also making sure
that they're fed well
the carrots the apple slices
good snacks quality snacks for
youngsters
vilsack also pitched president biden's
infrastructure plan
which is currently in front of congress
next year on politics now
how to help the homeless for one thing
they needed
was community they were lonely
coming up we speak with the founder of a
local organization about the situation
on the ground right now with people
living on the street
welcome back to politics now
the latest homeless count puts the
number of people living without housing
in las vegas at about 6 000 people after
more than a year of a pandemic in city
ordinances in las vegas to address
homelessness
we wanted to know what the situation is
right now i spoke with meredith spriggs
she is the founder and chief kindness
offer officer
of cary data it employs the homeless and
helps through outreach
what we're seeing is we're seeing a big
increase
in visible street homeless and i always
judge it by the time of the month so i'm
seeing them at the beginning of the
month and
traditionally that's been when people go
indoors they get their pay whatever so
we're still seeing that
no break at the beginning of the month
and then an uptick
in um the substance abuse is what we've
just seen in our little little pocket
and that isn't to say that all homeless
are doing no of course not drugs
but it's just more visible than i feel
like in your face than it's been
traditionally
before the pandemic the city passed uh
some controversial ordinances which i
know you were involved in in fighting
against
uh with regards to camping on the
streets uh issues of homelessness
sleeping on sidewalks and so forth
they passed the impression i got from
talking with folks at city hall at least
is that
you know the pandemic overshadowed a lot
of that priorities were
elsewhere what is happening on the
ground from that level are those rules
actually still being enforced are you
speaking with folks that live on the
street that are that are homeless
that are dealing with this on a somewhat
regular basis
and what are your concerns we are and
what we're seeing is it's getting harder
for us to find people the
handful of people that we have that are
literally street homeless that we're
case managing
um they'll get rousted or they'll get
moved or they'll get
you know threatened with citations and
so then they move to areas
and so then we can't find them or they
get arrested and we can't find them so
it's really hard to get things done when
people are in jail and unfortunately
this is another
red tape loophole thing that we have
going on with the feds if someone is
in jail over 45 days they get taken off
the community housing list
so you basically by throwing people in
jail then are disqualifying them for
housing if it's
for an extended jail stay where is the
best place in your opinion to put that
money
to do the best good the most good
housing and transitional housing but
that's a long-term fix i mean
is there a short-term solution that can
be done
that would alleviate some of the
pressure
i can't really think of that anymore
because
because what we've done or just you know
work with landlords right now also
affordable housing is a thing
i used to be when i had clients coming
in that had a fixed income of 733 a
month
they could find a place even in downtown
now that's next to impossible and it's
getting more competitive for renters as
homes are going away
so it's just hard to even rent now um so
how are people to find that so maybe
working
with landlords to get a master lease
would be great for now and you could
even
i know um some of uh i want to say it
was uh well care
welcome had a master lease on an old
super aid in town so they had covered
rooms
for those at risk and so they could put
them in there so those are hotel rooms
that have been repurposed they have a
master lease with them
the main agency they case manage they
make sure everything is good
and that's what they did here in la they
called it project room key they did the
same thing
put people in hotel rooms case manage
them and then that gave them kind of
respite until they could find housing so
they weren't out on the streets
when you talk to them i guess as a final
question
what do they say they need the most what
is their
aside from just a place to live which is
understandable but
what is the biggest complaint the
biggest concern they have on a
day-to-day basis
i think it would blow everybody's mind
but i think the viewers need to hear
this
when we did our surveys at the end of
the last semester with our practicum
student
the number one thing they needed was
community
they were lonely people on the streets
are lonely
people indoors are lonely what have we
done with our society
that we are so focused inwardly we're
individualized you know
we're on our phones we're segregated
isolated and now we're dehumanized now
we're other rising
and i think not only do we need these
great programs and the government i mean
it's a combo right
it's kind of like that that rubik's cube
of what you need
or tetris i guess it would be tetris to
put it all together to work
so it's you need the housing you need
the supportive services you need the
support of
the government and the private
private citizens and you need community
to surround them and help them
carry dad gardens is an indoor
hydroponic garden it's in downtown las
vegas around 11th and fremont
it hires formerly homeless people right
now mostly former veteran
vets i bigger pardon to work in the
garden and the produce goes to bars and
restaurants downtown it goes to anthem
medicaid members who get free produce as
well
the organization is currently expanding
we have a lot more on caridad gardens
and how you can help if you're
interested and the full interview we
talk about a lot it's an ongoing issue
as on eightnewsnow.com next on politics
now trying to break up nevada
the first meeting of a small group that
wants to cut clark county off from the
rest of the state
you're watching politics now
nevada and three dozen other states are
suing google for antitrust law
violations
these litigations center around google's
control of the google play store for
android devices
the lawsuits say they require apps to
use their payment process
and charge a 30 percent fee competitors
that those apps
claim those apps are not allowed to use
or charge two or three percent
the federal trade commission and
congress are targeting some of the
largest tech companies as well
they're accused of behaving like
monopolies that hurt consumers and other
businesses
the ftc and some lawmakers say
businesses like amazon
apple google might need to be broken up
our washington correspondent alex limon
reports
in its first public meeting under the
new chair the ftc voted to make it
easier for that agency to go
after big tech companies for alleged
monopolistic behavior
the federal trade commission says the
agency is ready to start more vigorous
enforcement of its rules
prohibiting conduct that is unfair
deceptive
anti-competitive collusive coercive
predatory
exploitative and exclusionary among
others
as part of that goal last week the ftc
voted to give itself
more power to go after companies in the
tech industry
and other industries that the agency
says are acting like monopolies
the rule changes allow the agency to
bring anti-trust cases when companies
hurt competitors
not just consumers and the ftc approved
greater use of subpoena power in its
investigations
enabling more expeditious investigatory
process
this is particularly important given
that we are in the midst of a massive
merger boom
the u.s tech sector is the envy of the
world matt shears
president and ceo of the computer and
communications industry association
says all businesses should play by the
rules but argues more regulations could
hurt american businesses
and consumers the consumers lose out
because it's
it's through that combat through that uh
aggressive
innovation and price cuts that the
consumers benefit
but many lawmakers agree with the ftc
that's why congress also recently
advanced a bipartisan package of bills
that could reshape or even
break up portions of amazon facebook
apple and google and congress is working
on that legislation because an
investigation by a house committee last
year
found that those four tech companies do
enjoy
monopoly power reporting in washington
alexandra limon
also former president donald trump
announced his own lawsuit against
facebook
twitter and google this week of course
he was banned from those sites earlier
this year after the january 6 capitol
hill attack
the former president is also calling for
changes to the way those companies are
regulated
as billionaires fight to lead the space
race
nasa is focusing on its own race to
space it's planning its first mission to
the moon in more than 50 years
washington correspondent kelly meyer sat
down with the nasa administrator
as they count down to take off a return
to the moon
exploring with spacex and identifying
flying objects
nasa's newest administrator has plenty
to keep him busy
but he tells me his new team is ready to
take off this is the core stage
bill nelson is surrounded by inspiration
to get america
back into space we've got a lot of
exciting things that we're doing
35 years after nelson launched into
orbit
he's back as the head of nasa truth be
known i'm like a kid in a candy shop
actual capsule now not only have the
crafts changed
so notice the different design but so
has who is sending them into space
groups like spacex and boeing are now
partnering with nasa to lower the cost
of space travel
encouraging the development
commercially of space nelson pushed for
this partnership when he was a senator
now as administrator he's seeing nasa
take off to new heights
in 2024 americans will shoot for the
moon for the first time in 50 years
aiming to land the first woman and
potentially first person of color
on the moon it's reflecting the
diversity of our country
the first test flight is scheduled for
liftoff by the end of this year
in a spacecraft that could push humans
further into space
than ever before we're going to launch
the largest most powerful
rocket ever with the help of new
partners and developing technologies
nasa is entering a new generation of
exploration
nelson can't wait for it to take off we
are
right at a new dawn of the space age
and it is an exciting space age and as
far as what else is out there nelson
admitted to me he just doesn't know but
he is working with scientists at nasa to
find out what the reports of
ufos may be reporting in washington i'm
kelly meyer
of course if you want to know more about
that government ufo report that kelly
just referred to you can of course head
to mysterywire.com
george knapp and the team have been on
top of it from the very beginning
a group calling itself the new nevada
movement held its first
in-person town hall meeting in pahrump
this week
so the group's goal is to cut clark
county off from the rest of the state
it plans to try and get members who
agree with their movement into the
legislature for the 2023
session on politics now coming up next
working to help fix a critical blood
shortage
you're watching politics now
the red cross says every two seconds
someone in the u.s
needs blood the u.s is now experiencing
a severe shortage
all across the country nevada senator
catherine cortez masto donated blood at
the american red cross here in the
valley to raise awareness
here in the community right now there's
an urgent call for donors especially
those with typo blood
if anybody was here after october 1 2017
you saw the need not only for blood at
that time but you saw the impact that
red cross had
as part of the community coming in
supporting our community supporting the
families
the victims of survivors and we had a
blood shortage at that time
that's no different now if you're
interested in helping you can make an
appointment at the
red cross's website we have a list of
the upcoming drives
at eight newsnow dot com
this week in what to watch spending
federal money
clark county has 440 million dollars to
spend for
affordable housing and to help create
jobs so we're taking a look to see what
ideas might come out of
next week's public meetings and see how
the county and the cities
will go from here that is coming up next
week and we'll certainly keep an eye out
we thank you very much for watching
politics now all your political news at
8newsnow.com we'll see you right back
here next week thank you for joining us
you